bonjour ma très chère julie tient
monsieur 19 bonjour alors comment vous
portez-vous mon enfant sache les
nouveaux vous m'appelez votre enfant
maintenant oui enfin non pas là c'est à
dire que j'ai vu dans un livre que les
grands de ce monde appelait les jeunes
filles monotonie et tamponné ma
distinction à noblesse et surtout au
titre de président de la fed de 90 ans
je pensais que je pouvais vous appeler
ainsi notez bien que ça m'est égal mais
ça m'a donné tout à coup l'impression
que vous aviez vieillit pas pour vous
vous croyez laissez tout à fait
l'impression que ça m'a tenus mais ça ne
donne pas le résultat que j'escomptais
et vous êtes sûr que ça n'ajoute rien ma
noblesse à la distinction
je suis désolé mais j'en suis absolument
certaine je n'y ai pas pensé une seconde
que la sedis nab
vous n'auriez pas dû vivre à cette
époque vous je vous vois en train de
manger des mets délicats dans des
jardins à la française
ici vous n'avez que quelques arbres et
le gloubiboulga casimir
vous avez tout à fait raison ma chère
amy je comprends à présent pourquoi je
n'apprécie pas le bonheur parfait
lorsque j'arrive dans ce jardin et vous
comprend d'où par contre ainsi que
françois et notre brave emile est un
décor simple pour des âmes simples et
oui on s'est un peu médiocre je sais
mais que voulez vous de plus marienne
plus je trouve le jardin très jolie
comme ça et il y aura casimir en train
de manger du gloubiboulga sur le banc ça
serait parfait hommage et rapide ne
parlez pas un seul mode cloud by bull
gamme relève le cut
je me permets vous quitter ma chambre au
revoir au revoir monsieur 19 un jardin à
la française
c'est une idée khoudri hawaï est une
belle première bonjour julie à bonjour
mes enfants sans l'imam en vain cadillac
est un esprit de répartie toi pourquoi
dis-tu sort et figurez vous monsieur du
snav bien d'arriver en
disant bonjour mon enfant à je ne
pensais pas qu'il était si vieux que ça
peu près ce que j'ai pensé mais lui
croyait que ça faisait très bien haut
pour monsieur des snobs
à force de vouloir paraître une personne
de qualité mais d'un venu complètement
par k -o casimir se présente souvent
d'accord il est seulement à moi qui est
ok même pas casimir mais chacun sa façon
de voir les choses bourse à celle de
monsieur des snobs est un peu
particulière c'est vrai mais c'est pas
pour ça qu'il est fou stupide et casimir
toi même dû parfois des idées un peu
curieuse un oui l'ès pas tu aimes le
lobby boulga par exemple ben oui on peut
d'ailleurs tu m'avais promis de me
préparer un voyou et tu ne fais le voilà
au marché français depuis hier et va le
manger sur le banc oh mercy jolie régal
toi ils ont l'air vraiment délicieux
abomination monsieur disnat comment
allez-vous mon enfant très mal je ne
permettrai pas ne te manquer de voir
plus longtemps vous avez l'air très en
colère prenez un peu de gloubiboulga
savoure mettra de bonne humeur lors de
ma venue de mon odorat et puis
d'ailleurs il est temps de parler net tu
t'emportes plus toujours si ce jardin
est un hymne à tout le monde et
n'importe quoi qui allait les enfants
marchent sur les pelouse
françois ne porte même pas de cravate et
on va supporter le gloubiboulga mais
tout ça c'est terminé
il a un de trop sur cette île et tais
toi moi oui parfaitement
d'ailleurs j'ai là c'est cette feuille
le projet de leur prochaine aux enfants
que je conduis moi même mais ce sera
grandiose
cette fois françois ne pourra pas dire
que monsieur du snav n'est pas
complètement toqué je vous salue
monsieur chers amis bonjour à nouveau
oui bonjour
l'heure est grave mais grandiose à
confondre le netto rien à bas coûts ne
voulions pas vous interrompre et non
c'est vous même qui venait nous dire de
nous taire dans pardonnez moi mais je
tiens à me suis jamais nerveux aussi ce
jour est tellement important pour moi
tenez regardez assez joli ans est
étonnant c'est avec les tableaux mais
non mais non c'est intéressant ça dit
monsieur le snob
j'espère que vous ne l'avez pas payer
trop cher parce que c'est pas un vieux
tableau ça combien avez vous payé sans
indiscrétion mais qu'est ce que ça
représente juste un jardin à la
française c'est ça je le vois bien
m'aimer où se trouve-t-il qu'il a
dessiné mon pacifique s'ils arrêtent les
poses des questions aux 100 questions ce
qu'on va peut-être vous réponds non
excusez-nous ce jardin n'existe pas
encore c'est moi qui l'ait dessinée et
va être installée ici même parfaitement
il est temps que nous enfants
connaissent une pop de grandeur et de
distinctions mérite revient comme ça il
nous en faut mais oui nous y sommes très
heureux oui oui je reconnais la halle
influence néfaste de casimir
mais les travaux commencent dès demain
et j'interdis la fabrication du lobby
molleda de quel droit vous oublié
peut-être mon cher ami que je suis le
président de la fed d'une maison quelle
mouche l'a piqué je le nom moi je vois
une solution au point empêcher monsieur
du snob de faire son jardin français
areva
comment est ce possible il faut qu'il
reste dans son rôle il avoue aimer
comment parvenir à ce résultat
voilà ce que nous allons faire
nous allons d'abord faire semblant de
l'invité un grand festin
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout est prêt
attention le voilà vite puis tu casses
toi derrière le coeur du 18ème la
marquise baron je viens à l'instant même
de recevoir votre invitation ce qui
explique mon très regrettable retard
oui mais vous êtes tout excuser merci à
ses yeux le haut après vous et bien vous
allez tous bien entendu à votre tour
excusé nous car nous ne nous attendions
plus et nous avons déjà fini notre repas
rouge
je suis navré vraiment mon ami mais
manger ça mettra sûrement pas mais voilà
il s'agit d'une recette que j'ai
rapporté d'un de mes nombreux voyages
aux antipodes 120,5 me sens pas sinon je
vous aime aussi le vélo tauzia semé de
la haute société il pas de loup de paris
[Rires]
c'est férié rate amusant car le grand
chic c'est la manger beaucoup et très
vite mais je dois pas laissé une miette
dans le cna comme en voit un gentilhomme
vous ne le saviez pas mon ami mon ami
vous vous sentez pas bien aux jeunes au
coeur ce plat ici l'étrange vous ne
connaissiez pas
à vrai dire tout cela s'appelle du
gloubiboulga vous voyez c'était pas bien
difficile de la l'envoyer pour quelques
jours dans son lit
[Musique]